nearly all abortions could be banned in
south carolina under a new law to be
signed by the state's governor
the legislation was approved in the
state house yesterday after the senate
passed it last month
according to a research group that
supports reproductive rights 11 states
have passed a so-called
heartbeat abortion ban or something more
restrictive although all have been
blocked by
courts meanwhile a handful of states
have moved to protect
or expand abortion rights senior
investigative correspondent catherine
herridge
is following this story from washington
catherine good morning well anthony good
morning planned parenthood says more
than 200 anti-abortion bills are pending
at the state level
and 30 states have at least one abortion
ban under consideration
yesterday in south carolina the state's
democratic caucus
walked out during debate of the bill
which bans abortion if
fetal cardiac activity is detected which
happens
at around six weeks the democratic
caucus will exit
the house floor and leave you all
to the farce which is a debate about
life in the end it was passed by a vote
of 79
to 35 there are exceptions for rape
incest and if a mother's life is in
danger
if signed into law an abortion provider
who violates it could face prison time
and a ten thousand dollar fine data
shows a surge in state legislation
restricting abortion after the trump
administration confirmed
supreme court justice brett kavanaugh in
2018
and more recently amy coney barrett in
october later this week the supreme
court will consider
whether to take a case challenging roe v
wade which legalized abortion in 1973.
if it's overturned it would fall back to
the states where these more restrictive
laws could govern gail
all right catherine thank you very much